- sous leur poids et puis les notes m
elles sont blanches l'époux aussi font
leur rentrée
chaque année près d'un enfant de moins
de 10 ans sur quatre risque d'en
attraper et à chaque génération
l'insecte à six pattes à traumatiser
parents et enfants oui c'est long à
rattraper quand on secoue alors lèverait
pour principe cerveau mais les landes ce
qu'on appelle les landes c'est un peu
plus clair et ça reste accroché aux
cheveux simple contact échange de beaune
est l'époux prolifèrent vite sur la tête
des enfants dans les années soixante dix
les écoles françaises subissait une
recrudescence du parasite une émission
entière était alors consacré au sujet
depuis le mois de septembre
j'entends parler de poux et on a pu me
signaler la maîtresse m'a signalé un
jour que ma fille avait une lente que je
n'avais pas vu parce que je n'ai jamais
lu ni de l'anc et nids de poux longtemps
assimilé à un manque d'hygiène la
pédiculose du cuir chevelu autrement dit
le pouls a longtemps été considérée
comme une maladie honteuse
particulièrement auprès des parents
cette directrice d'école en témoigner en
1978 ils ont honte d'avoir les enfants
qui ont des peaux même s'ils sont pas
responsables auraient été contaminés et
leurs enfants ne peuvent pas avoir de
plus a priori
alors pour s'en débarrasser tous les
moyens sont bons
peigne shampoing vinaigre ou
insecticides en 1976 cette femme optait
pour la dernière solution et elle n'y
allait pas de main morte
étape importante bien saupoudrer avec un
insecticide à base de ddt ou d'exact
l'euro cyclo exane toute la literie et
d'une manière générale tous les endroits
où les enfants a pu poser sa tête
mêlée pour résister traverse les âges en
il était toujours la bête noire des
parents l'année dernière elles ont été
remplies
et c'est un calvaire d'ailleurs pour
s'en débarrasser parce que les parents
qui soignera ces dernières années des
coiffeurs spécialiste de l'insecte à six
pattes viennent à la rescousse des
parents dans les centres anti poux le
parasite n'a plus aucune chance
[Musique]